welcome back to the morning toast we
have such an
exciting guest of honor today we are
joined by
lala kent who perhaps has had the
busiest most productive year
of any of us yeah she had a baby she
wrote a book she started a baby line now
you're back
filming vanderpump rules hi lala how are
you
hi my loves i'm so good how are you
we're so excited to
give them la la before we talk about
the definition what does that entail
giving lala
well so originally give them la la when
i exited the show
season five and people were you know
sending me messages being like why did
you leave and so i was like give the
people what they want give them lala so
it came from a very like
egotistical uh place
as i got older and i like to say as i
matured
and evolved it became something where it
was more of like just be who you are and
give them who you are
and do it unapologetically so it took on
a whole different meaning
definitely well we just had a chance to
read your book give them lala which
wherein you do give us a lot of lala and
a lot of lauren
and i felt like the book was so
heartwarming first of all so
congratulations
on writing a really wonderful memoir
it's so nice like as someone two people
who are such big fans of yours it's so
nice to see every different side of you
and we've
it must be you must feel such peace
right now
i really do and the reason i decided to
write the book was
it wasn't because i thought that my
story was just so interesting that it
had to be told it was
obviously that was a part of it because
you want people to be entertained when
they're reading your book
but it was really just me wanting to
to purge a lot and you know when you
enter reality tv and you only see
you know an hour episode for however
many weeks
it it doesn't always make sense why
someone is the way
they have turned out to be like what did
they go through in their little lifetime
that made them like
want to clap back and do all of these
things
so for me it was like getting rid of the
scarlet letter on my chest when it came
to
how my fiance and i came to be and
really just why
i kind of react the way that i do and i
was hoping that that would be relatable
for people
and for people to feel less alone and
less hard on themselves
yeah no that definitely comes through
does it feel like this weight has been
lifted off your shoulders now that
you've shared your story i think it was
like on the last page where you said
you know this book is meant to like
answer your questions and that is it i'm
like here's
are your answers and you can refer to
the book so is it nice to have that
weight off of you
it's so nice and
strangely going into this season of
vanderpump rules
i've actually felt so different
about things where before it was like
i would think about every single move
that i was making and then beat myself
up for things and once
you know i wrote this book and kind of
told my story
this year going into filming and kind of
just my day-to-day life
it's like i don't need to explain this
to you like things happen
life isn't perfect i don't really need
to explain why this that and the other
happened
it's probably gonna happen again and i'm
okay with that
yeah and don't you think that's also
just kind of like a growth part of
becoming a mom now it's like you don't
sweat so much with small stuff
oh absolutely i and it i don't want to
say that i don't
care about these little things that may
happen in life because i definitely am a
human being and i'm affected
you know i when i'm clapping back at
someone i definitely don't go home
and say oh i'm so glad i said that i'm
gonna sleep great tonight
you know so i'm still affected but as
long as
when i come home it's like i have this
little healthy human being
and the rest of the stuff will work
itself out
yeah it puts everything in perspective i
imagine totally
yeah how has it been filming this season
now everyone all the bander babies are
running around has that really changed
what we can expect from the show this
season
you know i want to say that it will but
kind of not
good we're still just as like
crazy and i at the beginning before
we started filming people would ask
after the show got picked up what can we
expect from this season of vanderpump
and
you know i really didn't know because
the dynamics are different
you know we've lost a part of
the show which you know just because our
friends were let go from the show we're
still
very much involved those just because
they're not on a show doesn't mean
they're not in
our in our day-to-day life so and and
those
people that were were let go they
weren't just like little
flimsy cast members those people brought
it every episode so
that i was worried about and then
obviously becoming a
mom i'm like am i just gonna sob every
episode which i probably do
but it's in the state of california you
can only film
a baby of my baby's age and sheena's
baby's age
for 20 minutes and then they've got to
go bye-bye
yeah and if there's not a a
teacher i know i'm like what are they
learning i don't understand
yeah yeah she doesn't even know what's
going on but they have to have a teacher
and also a nurse
on location so if those people are not
available then
the babies can't make an appearance at
all so i don't know how much you'll
really
see of of ocean and summer oh that's so
interesting
is it look weird because if like jackie
said we were actually just talking about
this earlier like people who had babies
in quarantine like
really made the most of this year like
it wasn't a waste of a year for you like
you literally became a mom you started a
family
and you're you go from you know spending
every
moment with your child so then having to
go back to work and filming and did you
struggle with that at all
oh yeah i still struggle with it it's
there are days where my schedule is
jam-packed
and excuse me with you know
filming or whatever little things that i
need to get done during the day
and then there are days that are you
know a little bit more relaxed that i
can spend
every waking moment with her but the
days that we have to
leave for an entire day it's definitely
difficult
but i i have had the luxury of i've had
a night nurse
so i get to kind of pass her off and get
a good night's sleep
and during the day i have some someone
come in to watch her which
you know is again a luxury but
i'm i'm very envious of sheena who gets
to leave her baby with her
her mama oh yeah that's nice
yeah it is nice so it
it's definitely a struggle leaving your
kid behind but every
person who has to be a working mom has
to do it so it is what it is
yes you also launch even lala baby which
is so exciting it's so cute what made
you want to start that
my best friend from back home in utah
our moms have been friends since junior
high and then we were
born a year apart so she had reached out
and said i really want to start
a baby line she already has one and she
said i want to do another one with you
and i was like well i don't have kids so
it wouldn't make much sense and then
when i found out i was pregnant
and we knew the ocean was healthy and
happy i was like let's
let's start it and i want to launch like
not long after she arrives
onto this planet so that was kind of
what was behind it and
also it's so fun to play dress up with
babies i was like why not
be able to dress her up in my own stuff
and do you
share bottles with the baby
i do not because she's not on formula
she's on the boob
but when when she does have a bubba i'm
like this is liquid gold i
i can't i can't take this from her
i feel like you were foreshadowing you
know in those scenes what was to come
for you it was really beautiful
i love that you say that i think people
watch that scene they were like
this [ __ ] needs massive amounts of
therapy
to understand why she sucks on a bottle
but no i actually can i tell you once i
gave up
alcohol my anxiety dropped so
much i can imagine so yeah like the
bubba was not even
needed much anymore so now just the baby
has the bottle
yeah i think that's actually been one of
my favorite parts about watching your
journey on the show because you've
always been like so fun
and so real and you know you're a man
made out of my friend catchphrases but
then i feel like
we saw a really earnest side to you and
i think the way you spoke about getting
sober and how you really wanted
to you know bring james on that journey
with you was just like a totally
different side of you
and i'm curious if your experience
filming has been easier or harder
because it is a show like about drinking
like
well not about drinking but about
friends who drink and i'm curious if
it's been
made more difficult or easier for you so
i can imagine how many you know panic
attacks you have when you drink on
television and then wake up the next
morning
what did i say what did i do oh i love
that you said that because that's
exactly
what would happen when i was drinking it
was like okay well that made for great
television but now i have to deal with
these feelings the next morning
of why did i say that did i say it in
the way that i remember
and now i can go and and i always
thought once i gave up alcohol i was
very worried i even talked to producers
like i don't even know that i'll be
interesting anymore for you guys
and i guess the crazies just in my veins
because
because i still was popping off just as
much without the alcohol
but now i can go home and kind of you
know
leave that part behind and know
this is exactly what happened and how it
happened there's nothing i can do about
it and we gotta move on so
that part the anxiety of oh my god what
did i do and say
is definitely not as heavy
that's delightful yeah it is delightful
i get that and i don't even film a tv
show i just like yelling right
i love that you're my type of [ __ ] then
you
can just walk around yelling at
everybody and
the best part about it is when i get
like a call time in the morning
i know like i can arrive and you know
know where i am in that moment before it
was like
wake up hit the bottle again because how
do you cure a hangover you have like a
lot of hair of the dog
yeah yeah so i think there's like this
feeling amongst
the fans of the show that there's like a
little bit of concern about the upcoming
season because we've lost so many cast
members then there was cobia you guys
weren't filming people are like is the
show even coming back so
tell us can you calm our nerves a little
bit
about what to like if it's going to be
good yeah there's a lot of questions
floating around people thought the show
was even going to be cancelled
no i know and we were kind of in that
same boat with you guys
we also were sitting here i think that
we
found out we were being picked up like
maybe the day before it was actually
released to the public that we were
being picked up we're kind of in
we're so in the dark so i was also
worried i'm like can we even
make a good television show and you know
day one it was like
oh my gosh we can still make a great
television show
it's it's we're back to the
the roots of vanderpump rules i think
season eight
everything got a little bit muddy it was
like who are these random people that
were
supposed to be invested in you know and
i'll probably be killed for saying this
but i'm gonna say it i was very
uninterested in last season
you know like it was hard for me to get
through an episode i'm like who is this
person that's dating so and so don't
care like what's happening with witches
of wheat
oh right what's going on with jackson
tom sandoval i want to know
um and this year it's very different
like i said we're back to the roots of
the show and
it's deep rooted issues that people have
and it's
it's been it's been crazy it really has
you love to hear that i show up the
filming
it's crazy i showed the filming and i'm
like
i was not expecting any of this to
happen
well you know i feel like your evolution
on the show is like you've really just
come such a long way and i can really
really see you and i've said this a
million times
i can really see you like not that far
down the road becoming a real housewife
with beverly hills it just feels like
that's kind of like the space you're in
in your life now and like
you are a housewife you live in l.a like
i feel like it's not that far off is
that something you would ever do
i definitely would do of course
who wouldn't want to become a housewife
i mean it's a completely different level
but i think right now
i'm still a little bit too young for the
space you know i have a
brand new baby i think maybe down the
line
i would be into it but then i watched
the show you guys and those [ __ ]
don't play
yeah like and i'm like i'm
tough in the space i'm in but would i be
as tough
in that space because they don't hold
back and it's
it's real life stuff that they're
talking about not that
that we don't but our show is very much
like
i don't want to say a watered-down
version but i mean no one's husband
is you know robbing p
exactly you said
well speaking of housewives we saw you
on salt lake city because you're from
utah did you watch the whole season of
real housewives of salt lake city do you
think it was a good representation of
your faith and we loved
seeing it it was a real treat oh that
makes me so happy i do
i loved it and people have such
they think of utah and they're like
that's a weird place
where it's like super white which it is
more so than you know not so i get that
but
it reminded me of the utah that i know
people struggling in the mormon church
and wanting to like
be done with it like these women [ __ ]
brought it and like that's the utah i
know there's a little bit of crazy out
there and it makes for
great tv and it's not so like
it's not as cookie cutter where i'm from
where as people think it is where it's
like people wake up they go to church
boring so they you know
they really did a great job i watched
every episode
and i hear that this next season is
insane you guys it should be pretty
twisted with you know the fbi and
everything
oh no and i've heard that they're like
in
it i think it's gonna be one of the best
seasons of the franchise yeah wow i
i think so too it's like they really it
was a great show and then this little
gem shop thing like
kind of brought to the next level it did
and you know jen
shaw is she's so sweet and i i
walked into filming and it was like a
high school reunion it was like
all of my friends that i went to school
with were like
her cousins or her brother and i'm like
this is so crazy because
i just expected right i just expected to
walk in and be like i'm from utah you're
from utah
no i like knew these people from back in
the day
so when i saw those headlines about gen
chad i was like
how could this be like happening crazy
yeah crazy wow well congrats on the book
everyone can pick it up it's called give
them lala
and she's looking sickening on the front
and the back
so check it out rules will be back any
minute now we really can't wait thank
you so much for being here congrats on
the book congrats on becoming a mom and
we're just so excited to see
where life takes you next we really are
thank you so much for having me i always
love
hanging out with you guys so thank you
so much thank you guys for listening
we'll see you tomorrow
bye